Are you going out now?Have you
yet to go to the racecourse?It
would be nice to win, thank you very much.Well
then,
you're a beautiful woman.But I'm all about
roundness.As I know, Kazuyuki doesn't like me.That's right, but she had an
unusual atmosphere about her.
Right, hey
Kazuyuki, I can't believe that's that person's room.
[Music] Mr.
Sakuragawa, that person was trying to save my child. An
ambulance. Mr. Sakuragawa,
don't worry about it, it's fine.
[Music]
That injury,
especially that kind of
stupid thing. It's outrageous.  It was a flying distance.I think it
was something called hitting the peak of a car, as you sometimes see in historical dramas, where it doesn't seem to matter if you get cut.